Crazy about your crush chances are they might also be into you here are seven share signs. Your crush likes you back one
They make time to see you
some people are naturally fast and known to be the queen bees and kings of texting but if your crush is
Especially shy and reserved and known to be unresponsive but makes time to see you
This is a dead giveaway that they enjoy your company too. They make excuses to get close to you
Do they ever brush their arm against yours or give you hugs?
Physical affection is sweet, and they might be trying to show you that they you know
like like you three
They remember the small details about you if they seem to know you more than you know yourself
Not only do they like you back but you've also found yourself a keeper
For they let you in on their personal life
How close is too close until it's time to make a move when someone is being real with you?
They let you in on their secrets that includes embarrassing stories
Thinks they aren't so proud of or memories that still haunt them. Congratulations
This means they feel at ease with you five. They develop an interest in your hobbies
Maybe you love playing League of Legends or enjoy baking if your crush who's usually not into those activities
Starts to play video games with you or bakes you cookies. They might be trying to impress you
six the act cold and distant randomly
Okay, this sounds weird, right?
But sometimes people especially shy ones try to seem like they don't like you fearing you don't reciprocate the same feelings
It's the whole fight-or-flight
Scenario deep down though
They hope you notice their absence and wants you to reach out
7 they make it obvious that they're single think it's too good to be true
Think again if they haven't friend-zoned you by calling you their sis or bro
then this is a sure sign they've already made up their mind about their feelings, but do they know you have
Be bold and make the next move. You never really know unless you try do any of these signs sound familiar
What's stopping you from asking your crush out? Please? Share your thoughts with us below also
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more helpful tips and share this video with
With your help we can reach more people and provide our support
Thanks for watching
You